chuckle what do you think of people in
leadership roles who cuss I see it in
coaching guys either totally use it or
are totally against it so swearing
cussing using foul language I think this
is pretty straightforward question I can
tell you that by no means am i a saint
and and you know I was in the SEAL Teams
for 20 years and when you've heard the
term swear like a sailor there's
actually a level beyond that and that's
swearing like a seal and so I I've you
know there's times in the SEAL Teams
were literally you know every single
word in a sentence would be you know a
swear word and and that's something that
when I go back and brief the team brief
the SEAL Teams right now on something I
go almost right back into that mode you
know not not quite as bad as I probably
was at the high point of my career where
I was well rehearsed and well trained at
foul language but uh but hey here's the
deal on a form like this where we're on
a podcast where you know many many
people listen to this including kids and
my kids and I try and utilize better
language now and I'll tell you what I
actually had a point where I sort of
said to myself me I'm not gonna do that
and I heard a podcast wait you're not
going to do what I'm not gonna Square a
lot I'm not gonna be an I'm not just
gonna square the whole time into podcast
and this actually happened because I
heard a podcast I listened to a podcast
where it was actually it was a
conversation you know normal podcast it
was a conversation going on between two
people and they were swearing so much
that I just said to myself man this
sounds ridiculous it just sounded it
sounded completely ridiculous
and I just decided after and this was
before we started our pie this was you
know maybe like two years ago I mean was
a long time ago I heard this podcast I
just said to myself and these people
sound stupid with so much swearing and
and it wasn't it what the thing is like
you listen to Joe Rogan or like a
comedic podcast and they're swearing and
in some people like for instance Joe
Rogan he swears he does it at the right
time and it has comedic impact or has
value when he does it so so that's
understandable but I've heard people
that they just it's it's just it doesn't
it ends up having no impact other than
just to make you say this person is not
very smart right so with that you know I
just try to keep it clean
but actually it's not even almost like I
don't consciously sit there and try and
keep it clean but you know I try and
keep it clean yeah is that kind of like
you know people most of us have this I
don't say problem but what was they like
like you know like very similar like how
it just did yes and I'm doing that it's
all kind of like that yeah it is it's
the same thing where when you hear
someone saying like like like as soon as
you you might not even recognize it at
first because we're so used to hearing
it yeah but if you pick up on it and
you're listening to a podcast and you
start to hear someone do that it's the
same thing you just say wow this person
really sounds stupid and they might be
smart and but this person sounds really
stupid and I'm not gonna sound like that
so that's pretty much where where my
opinion comes from and and why in a you
know what I have had a couple people hit
me up and say you know hey this is the
only podcast that I listen to that my
kids can listen to yeah and that's kind
of cool you know I appreciate that it's
pretty
it's pretty humbling to hear that people
are you know sitting there listening to
podcast with their kids yeah and I guess
humbling is the wrong word which
somebody hit me up on Twitter it's an
honor right in it's an honor that
doesn't feel like I deserve but it's an
honor to hear somebody's sitting around
and say oh you know I listen this
podcast with my daughter or I listen to
your podcast with my son and it's so
many good lessons to learn and that's
that feels pretty good yeah yeah and so
if I was to throw that out the window so
that I could drop some heft bombs yeah
doesn't really seem worth it because
what kind of a what kind of a linguistic
command do I have if the only way I can
get my point across is by is by using
foul language yeah you know hey the
funny thing is too is well I used to go
you know when I was in the SEAL Teams I
would go and literally like I said my I
would have whole sentence constructions
that would be nothing but F bombs right
and I would come home and in front of my
six six-year-old kid or whatever I never
swore in front of my kids and people
would be kind of surprised like if I had
a seal buddy over and they'd hear me
talk in my house and they'd say how do
you even do that how do you and I don't
know I've just been able to do it so
that was another thing you know these
podcasts will you go on the interwebs
they're there for I hate to say it but
they're there forever you know and you
can take them down but these are gonna
be these are out there so if you if you
want to be represented that way for the
rest of your life then you got to be a
little bit careful about what you're
saying yeah yeah that's um because I
kind of like swear no I don't like to
swear but I like when people swear and
stuff I think it's but just like how you
were saying like for example Joe Rogan
like he'll swear and sometimes I'll
swear a lot but it's perfect it's funny
one it needs to be funny it emphasizes
you know a certain emotion when it needs
to it's it's perfect and that's kind of
the reason why I like it because
sometimes it can be really fun it can be
fun to do
but overall there's a certain kind of
you can't help but kind of respect
someone who doesn't like use the word
like all the time where that doesn't say
um all the time or who doesn't say you
know all the time or no I'm saying or
whatever and and can can control that
and I think swearing is yet another one
of those things that some people it's
more of a weakness where they kind of
they don't know how to use it right they
just swear it cuz they swore my parents
were so I swear who cares kind of thing
and on top of that you do have to
consider who you're talking to
and in a podcast situation you're
essentially talking to everybody
regardless of who you you were trying to
talk to who you think or want your
audience to be it's everyone anyone who
presses the button it's gonna be
listening so if you don't care how you
come off anything good didn't that's
that's great but I think you do have
more of a control on how you come off
when you can control how much you swear
it don't swear well I haven't had
anybody you know hit me up on Twitter
and say hey you really need to swear
more right it doesn't happen didn't no
one said hey you need to say uh more
ready to say like more people don't need
to hear that they accept it because it's
there and I'll tell you a funny the
first time I took my you should take my
son out occasionally to various seal
training sites you know in order to
inoculate him to violence and Firearms
and machine guns and war and and yes
you've all people can all call child
services on me but it was funny the
first time you know he wants to see the
platoon do some event and I think he was
at a at a urban training facility and
they got done and I was debriefing them
and you know this is my son who had
never heard me swear and who kind of use
at that age where you know a swear word
was like heard worse ever and he you
know he was standing there and I debrief
these guys and I I debrief them in the
proper seal technique and I got done he
had a look at his face that said
Wow yeah this guy is a little different
than what I knew he was pretty shocked
and it was uh it was a pretty funny
scenario so you know you say you don't
swear in front of your kids why is that
because you don't want them to swear or
were yeah I mean there is you know if
you ever see a in and I do now that my
daughters are a little older I'll drop
some swear words in them in occasionally
for impact
or for humor you know or for whatever so
uh so I will do it but if you ever see a
young girl swearing mmm it you see a
young boy you know it very much seems
disrespectful you know in my opinion so
I don't want my kids to be running
around with a foul mouth now I took my
son and a couple of his buddies went a
little surf trip and they were sleeping
in a tent outside of and I was in the I
was in the camper and I woke up at when
I normally wake up and they were they
were up early to go surfing as well but
I was standing outside their tent and I
was pretty impressed with the wide array
of foul language is they produced yeah
that's right so it doesn't if you'd
never swear it to your kids it's not
like you have protected them for us
wearing so that that's my point is that
after I stood out there for a while and
I listened to them and then I said
something along the lines of hey are you
guys done and are you ready to go
surfing and my son says how long have
you been out there dad and and I swore
back at him I swore back at him and said
I've been out here long and then they
kind of remained quiet for a second and
then they started laughing I said
alright boys let's go so I'm not a goody
two-shoes I understand and you know we
talked about pat pat and swirl
incessantly amongst the troops and then
when he'd get in front of politicians he
would not and I guess I would
hope to behave that way and I used to I
used to go there was when we got back
from Ramadi I had to go and brief the
Secretary of the Navy had to go brief
the congruent I mean I had to go and
brief some high-level governmental
officials and whatnot and I were just
walking there not obviously you're not
gonna square them so I think that's
another another situation where you've
got a know and understand when to swear
and one win not to swear and I just
hopefully I'm making the right decisions
and like I said no one has no one has
hit me up and said you really need to
use more foul language yeah and you know
there's times where we've you know we've
used foul language on the on the podcast
because hey it's a reality it's a
reality of Vietnam it's a reality of all
wars yeah so to exclude it like it
doesn't exist is not what I'm trying to
do here yeah and that's kind of a big in
my opinion a big deal when someone you
can tell they're they're actively
pursuing not swearing we're in any kind
of especially a casual conversation
where they're about to say something and
then they then they use like I don't
know I don't know you know those reap
obvious replacing with what just it's
there's nothing wrong with it but it
does kind of kind of make you think oh
wait like so we can't just be ourselves
right now like we I don't know it feels
like you may not relate to it yeah you
know what's interesting is you seen for
Metal Jacket and we just an amazing
movie about the Marine Corps and the
whole the whole the whole first 45
minutes his boot camp and it's played by
Lee Rainie if it is his name and he does
he was a real drill instructor and so he
just nails it and I remember when my son
was six or seven years old I go yeah I
thought to myself I'll play him some of
this movie I'll just find some parts
that don't have any foul language there
are no parties the whole thing is just
completely over the top and it's awesome
so so there's definitely a time and a
place for it the other thing is for me
honestly
it's you know I was I'm always trying to
do better at stuff there's a challenge B
in trying to find words that are gonna
have impact without just going right to
the easy button on them on the big
f-bomb because that's gonna have impact
but if that's what you need to use then
it's just a little easy out that I don't
want to take every single time it
presents itself yeah I'll tell you when
I get when there's been a couple times
with my kids where they've stepped over
line I did something out of line mm-hmm
and when I would have sworn at them it
was like I slapped him in the face
because it was he having that much
impact where I was just throwing around
all the time it's taken away the impact
right right yeah so strategically it's
just best wearing yeah patent apparently
was from what I read he when he'd get
people fired up he'd do that on purpose
oh and then like even just a normal
conversation he didn't really sore that
much that's one of the things so he used
it as a specific tool you know to get
certain things done as far as influence
goes yeah I can't believe we've talked
for 10 minutes about swearing right it
needed to be talked about
hey we got asked the question